obviously you know as actors you're
you're getting into kind of you know the
emotional truth of the scenes and all
those things but equally
you've got to be like charles and diana
so
what are the shortcuts to get into say
charles what are the shortcuts
right yeah it goes right okay okay
i'll give you the stick spinning off
okay
so there's a couple of things that i
sort of
i mean i didn't spend too long kind of
dwelling on the little charles things
but there was one thing i noticed that
in every time he got out of a car
he'd do this thing still does it now i
saw something recently
anyway he gets out of the car and he
goes cufflink
cufflink so he goes checks the cufflink
checks cufflink checks his pocket square
and then waves so every time he goes to
a public
event or anything it's cufflink cufflink
pocket square i wonder if he's ever not
had his pocket square and then it's
completely
yeah without the grunt when he waves
yeah
and and he does speak in a very kind of
uh because it must be hard not to just
do an impression because people do do
impressions of it
i think i think so much about the crown
is sort of doing a bit of that sort of
work i don't know what you think emma
but i think it's
kind of finding little things that make
people feel safe in the knowledge that
you're not just
doing some something random you feel
like it is
you recognize something of charles so
with charles for instance
uh he does the thing he just thinks his
voice
where he sort of like speaks yes so
everything's like through teeth
he is
[Laughter]
what are the shortcuts for diana um
diana's
for her voice um it's mainly that
everything goes
sort of goes down at the end so her
pattern of speech so it's sort of like
my word to get into her was always like
was always all right
all right yeah and that's just what i'm
saying all right
but then everything she says sort of um
always goes down at the end so
it's almost like even if she had the
best time ever it was always sound a
little bit
sad but
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i used to spend most of my time trying
to perfect my alright i'll do it do it
um hang on you do it with a tilt though
head tilt
all right
thank you